but wouldn't you say that saying a whole  gender is trash and ain't [ __ ] and what  did you let me let me let me finish let  me finish what did you say that's Miss  sandristic so like wouldn't you say that  is open sexism against men  he is a no no but I'm asking about that  specific I think no one everyone should  be allowed to voice their own opinion  facts but what they're allowed to say  should be like oh no level you know just  so people are aware of them sort of  people in the world so we don't try so  they're not trying  I'm sorry guys guys guys guys guys guys  so I'm saying I'm saying like should it  shouldn't the women be banned that are  saying men ain't [ __ ] because is it I  think that's worse to say a whole gender  isn't [ __ ] oh wait let me finish I what  I think it's worse to say a whole I  wouldn't weigh it let me finish let me  finish I think it's worse to say a whole  gender isn't [ __ ] and it's trash I think  that's worse than saying oh